voici ce qui change en france à partir
du 1er février les parents de bébés nés
en février recevront les premières bbbox
qui contiennent une turbulette un album
et un savon le prix de l'électricité va
augmenter de 4% le prix de la plupart
des paquets de tabac à rouler va
augmenter de 20 centimes le tarif des
péages va augmenter de 2% le taux
d'intérêt du livret a passe de 0 5 à 1%
à partir du 2 février le masque ne sera
plus obligatoire en extérieur et les
jauges disparaîtront pour les publics
assis à partir du 15 février le
certificat de rétablissement qui retarde
la dose de rappel suite à une infection
coved 19 ne sera plus valable que quatre
mois et note que six le 16 février les
discothèques rouvriront et les concerts
debout sont également réautoriser